here we go this is a key undef initely
not first viewing of this movie but we
haven't seen in a while which it was
you're a favorite of the Batman films
not yeah not the longest time like the
first day after I saw cuz I was like
obsessed with Jim Carrey when he came
back was in 1985 you you could show me
Batman and Robin Dark Knight Rises
Batman V Superman as long as a
hitchhiker old and this guy shows up it
was not the best one honest trailers had
the best saying goodbye I said yep this
is definitely the worst movie I've seen
40 times like then that is kind of it
that that's definitely but this is our
parts of it I don't mind so if it's on
like ice occasionally will actually like
kind of sit through moments of it before
I change a chance but but we don't give
it a pass like a lot of our people it's
okay if I it's like it's really not but
it's not bad Robin here we go Batman
Forever it's like this looks kind of
lame now but back then when we saw these
credits it was like how did everything
in a gym case like coming right at me
yeah this is an opening for high people
this literally was the McDonald's
commercial Batman Returns had a big
issue we can't sell Happy Meal toys and
this one's like oh yeah the first line
is gonna be a commercial line okay so
that Batmobile is complete nonsense but
I kind of love it
it's not Batman but I love it this is it
enjoy this one moment this is the only
serious moment you will ever get out of
Tommy Lee Jones in this film yeah where
he's not goofy he's actually kind of
intimidating
so let's turn out of here what was that
I forgot we're in the red-light district
she just looks like she's touching
yourself under the camera every second I
just get to a compilation of all his
monkey burps really Mojo Jojo has more
dignity than this guy when the
technicals of this must have been pretty
crazy filling an entire safe whenever
has the most clueless Batman face I will
give a little bit of credit Christian
Bale's
is a little bit more clueless you know
he literally has a utility belt is there
nothing to enhance his hearing a matter
don't you love it when your main and
tagging this goes you know with all the
creative architecture in the city we
just throw in a Statue of Liberty lazy
dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb
dumb dumb
we will never name names but we have all
in the industry encountered this famous
oh yeah this part gets a little better
every time I see this is the best part
of the movie I'm just like wow this is
this is real at first I was like oh yeah
okay shit I'll say it
I forgot how gorgeous this movie is this
is telling you there is there's a decent
movie trying to get out of this
my characters complex it's poor my
life's an open book you read Wow I heard
that last week and a Fridays and I
thought that guy's desperate don't get
me wrong I was the one that said that
and I said the guy is desperate I know
I'm desperate I was drunk
oh my god I have like three pages
already and we're like one 15 minutes
oh my god I'm calling security
right after I fire Lucy from her latest
job this movie really likes fishing yeah
Rob this this may be stupid a little bit
told that's what Tommy Lee Jones called
him he looks at 911 yep definitely an
accident I want to be big so he's pretty
much ripping off whatever this other
Riddler character that exists in this
universe I just like how the Riddler
machine is way creepier than the Riddler
yeah I prefer healthy expressions of
violence as opposed to breaking and
entering now hitting a man dressed in
rubber you have a thing for bats oh
that's a war shot mr. Ryan question
would be
you everything prevents here's the real
question what the hell else could you
possibly see in that the terrifying
they made it music join us in a
celebration of absolute chaos
and true something about the reveal
their the music it like it's two-faced I
didn't know only that side of the
audience knew it what the hell do you
want Harvey clearly not Oscar I got mine
I'm good
Harvey he's back homie cheese man I have
enough time to be people falling on top
of me in hindsight that did not look
like a very threatening explosion no ha
ha nothing in their food yeah hi I'm
Jessie candy it was a giant pinata I was
going candy on the curd jackasses
no you said I I killed him why would I
say you killed him Alfred oak rice you
know what I'm out never shows up on the
rest of the movie flew in like a Robin
I think Robins are lame birds never
really cared for them good night but
your father was right the first time
anyway and he does exactly that
ha ha hey you got served by Alfred
that's my finger insults I'll let you
mourn and that Gaga would fall straight
off he fall down Bambi would be dead I
never knew how to feel about that it's
like it's so stupid but there's
something kind of cool about seeing it
just right over building don't worry
baby she's filming her next movie 50
do-overs I simply love what you've done
with this place
heavy metal meets house and garden this
was a mistake
honestly this is the first time I ever
noticed that the cartoons they're
watching reflect they're like you know
one cycle of the WB you never noticed
that really well let's see Doug drew
Barrymore and some other hot chick
dressed in lingerie no I wasn't watching
the fucking car number muggy the diaper
man who is Batman and how can we sell
him in Happy Meals actual file footage
of people watching Batman Forever
huh I'm watching Wookiee porn doesn't
look like they're touching themselves in
this movie everybody does
shooter alert let me turn on all the
computers raise up the Batmobile do
whatever you want intruder it's all
yours what is with her office like with
the giant paintings in there well she
needs some man to look at her when she
comes out of the dressing let's talk
about in front of my city curtain I mean
thank you
I just don't know yeah look at that you
hear that the boss did the whistle
that's our game language attack that man
just shows up and just sees Chris
O'Donnell's crumpled bloody third kid I
adopted your parents I accidentally
killed Kay and what a grand pursuit you
must be here and there it is the only
reason she has the name change
merchandising rights you're ruining my
big party he's actually okay when he's
not the Riddler honestly when he's nygma
I like him a lot better yeah it's like
the mask guys you like him better as
stanley ipkiss I hate the extras no take
that birds birds birds everywhere
brights what's a good sidekick name how
about Dick Grayson college dude screw
you I already graduated from college
like five years ago
so with midnight-ish she was still
sleeping hi didn't think you'd actually
come oh my god that was just a one-liner
like I was dead asleep how do I get a
better agent that's a good summary of
crystal Dawn's role in all this he's in
between too bad the hands yeah find us
all in a tennis court lots and lots of
white people wait wait did we just get a
shot Schumacher did you shoot you didn't
shoot that did you how does their jet
fly from an upside down lie I just
detached sneak
oh you push the green button I have no
idea what that means
pull my finger I can't I'm up here then
I shall call it myself yes you like
question marks you know what there's not
much of in this place riddles there's
very few Reynolds why didn't they just
call you punctuation man he has r2d2
Revenge of the Sith powers it was busy
being renowned men in black 3 so let me
do the math here but I didn't bring you
and I've gotten this done a lot faster I
only have two great yeah I'm already
regretting this head to rescue her and
that's it I hope in the movies like no
it's not about revenge is just like I
take no join this is now about revenge
yeah really
first time we've seen our Co so are we
not a thing I guess okay I'm just gonna
leave it up to the next movie which I'm
sure will be a great hit and they never
made another Batman no that was the last
Batman movie bad that is the last we
have seen the Batman and Robin it was
Batman Begins yep it's still pretty
stupid I can't believe how much I'm
actually totally buying the box
commentary that really was weird things
in the movie you imagine that dumb plot
line would have aged the best then you'd
be like ah yeah that was the internet
man like that was hacking you know who
would have thought and I'd still even
though that Tommy weed it's not Jim
Carrey it's Tommy Lee Jones is the worst
thing of this movie he's the worst but
also than all what's a nigger from
Batman Anonymous but it's for somebody
who apparently like went up to Jim
Carrey's like I don't approve of your
buffoonery and all but Chris and Jim
Carrey the funny thing is I don't like
him is Riddler like I could as kids over
it like everybody likes the Riddler and
that's apart laughing as an adult I'm
like his Edward nygma I bike is honestly
pretty good okay it's a lot of fun it is
long like and then part of it is the
action seeds don't add up to anything
yeah so I think you guys so much you see
you later bite
who's that you'll never find out haha
you